Ja, hier, wir werden schon...
Ist schon jemand bei der Arbeit, ja gut, alles klar.
Gut, los geht's.
Guten Abend.
Ja, hallo.
Mein Name ist Eilorban.
Ich bin hier der zuständige Arzt für Pulsi und würde gerne mit Ihnen was an einem Nessgespräch führen.
Sind Sie beim Einfallstand?
Ja, natürlich, ja.
Ja, klar.
Also ich werde zuerst ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Perfektion stellen.
Dann kommen wir gut zu Ihren Beschwerden, ja.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ja, er ist Mario Dietrich.
Mario Dietrich.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Nachbarn muckstabieren?
Ja, D-I-E-T-R-I-C-H.
I-H-E-R-Dietrich.
Ja.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 39 Jahre alt.
39, wie wann sind Sie geworden?
Am 17.09.85.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Herr Dietrich.
Ich bin 1,84.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zuzeit?
89 Kilo.
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Ja, also ich darf keine Nüsse essen.
Und ich habe auch gegen Krässe, also dieses grüne Kraut, da habe ich auch eine heftige Allergie.
Also da habe ich mal richtig Atemnotanfälle bekommen.
Wie aussehen sich die Allergien und Gras?
Also diese Nüsse, da kriege ich total rote Flecken im Gesicht und das Juck.
Und Gras?
Diese Krässe, da habe ich eben so Atemnot bekommen.
Dann mache ich jetzt einen großen Bogen drum herum.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt, Oberhausärztin?
Ja, das ist Dr. Sieger.
Was wird Sie zu uns, Herr Dietrich, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, ich habe also solch einen heftigen Husten.
Ja, das ist aber nicht nur der Husten, ich habe richtig so ein enge Gefühl
und habe das Gefühl, dass ich so ganz 10 Schleim in den Brunchen habe.
Und das brodelt richtig, wenn ich ausatme.
Und ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich also überhaupt nicht gut Luft bekommen
und gar nicht gut atmen kann.
Also seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ja, heute Nacht hat es angefangen.
Und dann hatte ich gehofft, morgen wäre das besser, aber es war eigentlich immer noch so schlimm.
Also die Beschwerden haben heute Morgen angefangen, oder?
Nein, gestern Abend.
Gestern Abend, ok.
Ich habe ganz schlecht geschlafen.
Also sind die Beschwerden plötzlich aufgetreten oder eher langsam?
Ja, also ich habe schon länger so eine Erkältung und Husten, aber dass es jetzt so ist,
dass ich so dieses Gefühl habe, dass das hier mit einmal alles so eng ist in der Brust,
das habe ich jetzt ganz neu.
Aber wenn Sie Brustschmerzen?
Brustschmerzen im eigentlichen Sinne, die Schmerzen sind das nicht,
es ist so dieses Gefühl, dass es alles viel zu eng ist.
Ok, ich möchte...
Also ist der Husten trocken oder mit Ausruf?
Nein, ich habe so ganz zähnen Schleim, aber ich kriege den fast gar nicht raus.
Haben Sie Fieber oder fühlen Sie sich fieblich?
Ich habe mich jetzt nicht gemessen, aber eigentlich fieber ich, so fühle ich mich eigentlich nicht.
Vor zwei, drei Wochen, da hatte ich mal eine richtige Erkältung
und ich habe immer mal so schnell Husten, deswegen habe ich auch mit der Raucherei aufgehört,
eigentlich weil ich immer wieder so leicht Husten hatte.
Also Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Probleme mit Ausatmen haben.
Also haben Sie die Probleme in Ruhe oder bei Belastung?
Sowohl als auch, eigentlich habe ich das ganze Zeit.
ganze Zeit, Luftmordprobleme.
So ein krasses Hals, ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass mein Herz ganz doll klopft.
Das macht mir wirklich Angst, muss ich sagen.
Haben Sie Beliederschmerzen, Möglichkeit oder Erschöpfung?
Nein, sonst eigentlich, also diese typischen Grippegefühle, das habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Okay, also ist der Husten meistens in der Nacht aufgetreten?
Sonst früher, da habe ich eigentlich immer mal wieder gehutet, ich habe mich auch schnell verschluckt.
Also das ist eigentlich schon lange so eine Schwachstelle
und sobald ich ein bisschen gereizt bin, muss ich, kriege ich immer ganz schnell Husten.
Aber so wie jetzt, das ist halt neu wirklich, dass ich das Gefühl habe, dass ich so keine Luft bekomme.
Okay, also Herr Dittrich, ich möchte jetzt unser Gespräch unterbrechen.
Also ich möchte Ihre Vitalparameter überprüfen.
Ich meine also Fieber, Blutdruck, oder Puls, Sauerstoffsetigung.
Und inzwischen möchte ich also eine EKG schreiben.
Also ich möchte nur an Sie sagen.
Also sicherheitlich ist das bestimmt ganz gut, ja.
Ja, ich möchte nur sicher sein, ob das alles in Ordnung ist.
Gut, dann können wir weiter machen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie seit wenigen Zeiten Husten haben, also waren Sie deswegen beim Hausarzt?
Ja, der hat gesagt, ja, Sie haben so ein bisschen ein, was hat er gesagt, ein hyperreagibles Brunchhalsystem, ja.
Das hat er schon vor langer Zeit gesagt, wie gesagt, ich habe deswegen auch mit dem Rauchen aufgehört.
Und ja, aber das ist eigentlich immer so, dass ich, wenn ich irgendwas kriege, kriege ich sofort Husten.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Herr Wittrich, leben Sie allein oder mit Ihrer Familie zusammen?
Ja, ich lebe mit Freunden zusammen.
Also hat Ihr Freund Enscher besprochen?
Sonst sind die alle bei mir in der Wohnung gezwungen, sind alle gesund.
Ja, da hat niemand Husten.
Haben Sie zuhause selbst Koranienstisch gemacht?
Und nachher habe ich irgendwann jetzt die Tami gemacht, ja, das war, also habe ich nach der Erkältung damals gemacht und jetzt auch nochmal, da ist aber nichts.
Okay, also haben Sie Herzweisen oder Herzstolpen?
Ja, also das Gefühl habe ich, dass das Herz also mehr klopft als normal, ja.
Haben Sie das Gefühl erst mal gehabt oder hatten Sie schon ein Leben?
Nein, das kenne ich eigentlich nicht.
Okay, leider unter Übelkeit?
Nein, Übel ist mir nicht.
Also mussten Sie erbrechen?
Nein, oh Gott, das will ich nicht.
Ich muss mich nicht übergeben.
Herr Wittrich, können Sie gut schlafen?
Ja, ich kann nicht so richtig gut schlafen.
Ich bin eigentlich so ein unruhiger Schläger, ich wache oft nachts auf oder kann schlecht einschlafen, ja, das ist nicht meine starke Seite.
Also müssen Sie in der Nacht öfter auf die Toilette gehen?
Nein, das eigentlich nicht, ich wache einfach so auf.
Können Sie flach schlafen?
Normalerweise eigentlich schon, aber jetzt, also letzte Nacht musste ich mich zwischendurch immer wieder aufsetzen und hatte das Gefühl, ich muss noch das Fenster aufmachen und habe mich also nicht gut gefühlt.
Und da habe ich mir dann auch noch ein extra Kissen, bzw. habe das Bett so ein bisschen hochgestellt, ja.
Wie viele Kissen benötigen Sie beim Schlafen?
Normalerweise eins, aber jetzt letzte Nacht habe ich mir eben noch ein extra Kissen geholt und habe das noch so ein bisschen schräg gestellt, mein Kopfteil.
Aber trotzdem habe ich nicht gut geschlafen.
Also haben Sie, Herr Witte, haben Sie Schwellung am Bein?
Haben Sie das bemerkt?
Beine? Nein, ich habe nur diesen Wusten.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Wasserlassen nicht, also beim Stuhlgang, ich bin schon ziemlich häufig verstopft, da muss ich ein bisschen aufpassen,
dass ich dann auch mal ein bisschen nachhelfen mit eingeweichten Flaumen oder Leinsamen oder so was, dass das ordentlich in die Gänge kommt, ja.
Bestell, haben Sie Stellproß oder Nachtschweiß?
Nein, schwitzen tue ich nicht in der Nacht, also auch letzte Nacht habe ich eigentlich nicht geschwitzt, ich hatte nur so dieses Gefühl, dass ich eben, dass ich keine Luft bekommen habe.
Bestell, haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Also mein Gewicht ist glaube ich stabil, ich hab mich, ich wiek mich ja nicht jeden Tag oder so, aber ich meine, dass das alles stabil ist.
Okay, Herr Wittrich, ich möchte jetzt ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Vorgestellung, weil denn Sie an Krönchen erkranken können?
Ja, also wie gesagt, mein Hausarzt hat behauptet, ich hätte so ein Hyperware, Giblis, Wohrenschalsystem, ja, aber das ist jetzt ja eine Veranlagung halt, dass man leichter da mal was kriegt.
Und sonst habe ich eigentlich nichts, weil ich eben auch viel am Computer arbeite, habe ich oft mal so Nackenschmerzen, ja, das sind eigentlich so meine einzigen Probleme.
Und ja, was ich noch habe, ich meine Hände und auch der Fußbereich, die reagieren so auf Kälte, ich muss also, wenn es kälter wird, ziemlich schnell Handschuhe anziehen, sonst kriege ich so eine ganz juckende Hautgeschichte und das wird alles rot und da muss ich so ein bisschen aufpassen.
Und wenn ich das nicht mache, dann muss ich halt so Cortisonseile benutzen, damit das wieder besser wird.
So, haben Sie Psyriasis oder?
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Also das sind keine Schuppen, das sind keine Schuppen, sondern das ist nur eben so bei Kälte, dass die Haut reagiert.
Okay, nur Hände und Füße?
Nur an den Händen und an den Füßen, genau.
Okay, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie hyperreagibel, reagibel, bronchiert Probleme.
Seit wann haben Sie das?
Oh, das ist schon, ach, das hat der Arzt mir vor Jahrzehnten, würde ich es nicht sagen, aber das ist schon über zehn Jahre her, dass der mir das mal gesagt hat.
Sie haben damals ein paar Medikamente eingenommen, aber jetzt nehmen Sie nichts.
Nein, also wenn ich Husten habe, dann nehme ich halt irgendwelche so Schleimlöser oder so, aber ich nehme nicht ständig irgendwas wegen des Hustens.
Okay, sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, ich hatte mal eine Knieoperation.
Also das war aber nur so eine kleine, so eine, wo Sie so reingeguckt haben ins Knie, ne?
Wann war das?
Lassen Sie mich überlegen, das ist so fünf Jahre her.
Fünf Jahre? Also warum hatten Sie diese O.K.?
Ja, ich hatte so viele Schwerte, ich konnte mit einmal mit dem einen Knie, das konnte ich nicht mehr bewegen.
Und dann haben die gesagt, da werden irgendwie so kleine Gelenkteilchen, die da frei rumgeschwommen sind und die haben die halt ausgespült.
Und seither habe ich eigentlich keine Probleme mehr.
Okay, super. Ansoßen hatten Sie keine O.K.
Nee, sonst bin ich noch nie operiert worden, das stimmt ja.
Super. Hier nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikament rein, Herr Dietrich?
Ja, also bei Bedarf, wenn ich halt irgendwie Schmerzen habe, dann nehme ich wohl mal so tipptrufe Nack, wenn irgendwie was weh tut.
Und dann eben diese Kortisosumsalbe und dann, wenn das mit der Verdauung zu blöd wird, dann nehme ich so Lefax-Cow-Tabletten, das fördert so die Verdauung.
Lefax-Cow-Tabletten. Ansoßen nehmen Sie...
Sonst nehme ich nichts, und das nehme ich auch nur weil wir da...
Okay, verstehe. Herr Dietrich, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie mit dem Rauchen aufgehört haben.
Ja, genau.
Also seit wann rauchen Sie nicht?
Seit drei Jahren rauche ich nicht mehr.
Also wie lange früher haben Sie geraucht und wie oft, wie viel Zekarente täglich haben Sie geraucht?
Ich habe immer ein Päckchen am Tag, habe ich schon gebraucht. Und das war, also ja, zehn Jahre lang war das.
Genau, das ist klar. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nee, also überhaupt nicht mehr. Mein Vater, da war ein schlechtes Vorbild, da ist Alkohol krank und er hat zwar in Zugbehandlungen gemacht.
Und ist aber völlig ohne Effekt, der ist einfach ganz, ganz schlimm Alkohol krank.
Und ja, das ist natürlich so, dass man dann sagt, lasst die Finger davon.
Mhm, klar. Herr Dietrich, nehmen Sie für nächste Frage nicht persönlich. Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nee, also mit Drogen, das habe ich gar nicht erst angefangen.
Ja.
Also Sie haben gesagt, dass Ihr Vater Alkohol abhängig ist.
Genau, ja.
Das ist korrekt, ja, ja.
Also leidet er an irgendwelchen Erkrankungen?
Zürichlich, sonst wüsste ich nicht. Wahrscheinlich macht ihm das in jeder Hinsicht fertig, aber das ist eigentlich so die Hauptsicht.
Bitte?
Zirose oder Fettsleber.
Wahrscheinlich hat er eine kaputte Leber, aber ich kann nichts genau dazu machen.
Keine Diagnose bespricht.
Also lebt Ihre Mutter noch?
Meine Mutter lebt noch, ja, ja.
Also leidet sie an Grundschritteerkrankungen?
Ich weiß, dass sie Ärger hat mit Nierensteinen.
Da ist schon mal was operiert worden und da ist sie immer mal wieder mit Beschwerden.
Ist sie da in der Klinik?
Das weiß ich wohl.
Okay.
Aber wenn Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich bin Einzelkind.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin ledig.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Kommunikationstrainer.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, nein, nein.
Okay, also, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie mit Ihren Freunden...
Mit Ihren Freunden, wir wohnen zu Vierteln.
Sind Sie voll geimpft, Herr Wiedrich, gegen Corona?
Ja, also ich meine, alles, was man so haben kann, also als Kind ja sowieso.
Und jetzt bin ich auch, also gegen Corona natürlich geimpft, klar.
Ja, und gegen FSNE bin ich auch geimpft.
Also alles, was man heute machen kann, ist,
habe ich.
Herr Wiedrich, ich habe alle meine wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Die Frage ist natürlich, wie es jetzt weitergeht,
was wir dagegen machen können, was die Ursache ist.
Wie geht es jetzt weiter, ja.
Ja, ich bin auch geimpft.
Ich bin auch geimpft.
Was die Ursache ist, wie geht es jetzt weiter, ja.
Also, ja, vermutlich haben Sie eine Bronschitis, also Lungen-Wex-Entzündung,
atypische Lungen-Wex-Entzündung, aber das ist nur eine Vermutung.
Lungen-Wex-Entzündung?
Ja, Lungen-Entzündung und entweder Lungen-Entzündung
oder Lungen-Wex-Entzündung auch es kann sein.
Wir sagen nicht Lungen-Wex, Atem-Wex-Entzündung.
Atem-Wex-Entzündung, okay.
Atem-Wex-Entzündung.
Aber das kann ich Ihnen zurzeit nicht genau sagen.
Ich muss erst einmal secure-fellisch unterdrucken.
Dann werde ich Bulleak abnehmen, dann ein paar Mastern,
wenn Sie spüren zum Beispiel Röntgen, Korax, gegebenenfalls Konfliktetomographie.
Also nach den Ergebnisse kann ich Ihnen mehr sagen, was Sie genau sagen.
Nach den Ergebnissen, ja okay, das klingt vernünftig.
Okay, möchte von den Kolleginnen und Kollegen irgendjemand noch zusätzlich fragen stellen?
Offensichtlich machen Sie es mir vollständig.
Sie müssen niemanden zu uns vorsetzen.
Ich brauche nur 30 Zöge.
Sie sagen einfach in Ruhe, wenn Sie in Ruhe Ihre Aufzeichnungen fertig haben
und dann sagen Sie, so jetzt geht es los.
Guten Abend und Frau Oberamstin.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patientin aufgenommen,
den ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Ja, okay, wir haben Sie schon gesehen.
Also Herr Mario Dietrich ist 39-Jähriger-Patient, 1,80 Meter groß, 89 kg schwer.
Herr Dietrich stellte sich heute wegen seit gestern Abend bestehenden Pustens
bei Brustco, er berichtete, dass der Pustens Zähflüssig ist, Zähflüssig sei.
Außerdem klagte er über Engagefür in Brustco und er gab an, dass er das Nöhrhans,
besonders Experiöme, also Ausatmung,
der Schwaltern, der Schwaltern, der Erwenten, der Tatsche, der Tatsche,
also der Erhardt Dizebechwerden, der Erstmalik.
Also früher hatte er Husten, aber mit diesem Symptome hatte er noch nie.
Also Husten mit deutschen Symptomen hatte er noch nie.
Also Fieber, auf Nachfrage Fieber, Torachschirmärtschen, Mäzis, Erbrochen, Fernains.
Und ja, intervegetative Anamnese leidet eher gelegenlich Obstipation.
Und beschwerde abhängige Schlafstörungen.
Er benötigt mehr als ein Kissen beim Schlafen.
Aber die ganze Zeit immer?
Nein, früher konnte er nur mit einem Kissen schlafen.
Aber in den nächsten Zeiten benötigt er extra Kissen beim Schlafen.
Bekannte Vorerkrankungen sind super reagierte Husten.
Reagibles Husten, Nackenschmerzen.
Und Renosyndrom.
Ah, okay, reinoh, genau, ja, super, genau.
So vor fünf Jahren wurde bei den Patienten eine Artroskopie durchgeführt,
wahrscheinlich wegen Artrose, von Artrose.
Sonst hatte er keine OP.
Er nimmt bei Bedarf die Knochenack und elf Fax Kau Tablete.
Seit drei Jahren ist er nicht drauf.
Früher hatte er fünf Päckichier.
Er trinkt keinen Alkohol, drogen Konsum wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese ergab sich bei der Mutter Scholelithiasis.
Und beim Vater Alkohol abhängig.
Als soziale Anamnest ist er ledig.
Und Kommunikationtrainer von Beruf hat keine Kinder und lebt mit ihren Freunden.
Er ist voll geimpft gegen Kinderkrankheiten und Corona.
Nach den Anamnestischen Angaben habe ich einen Verdacht auf Asthma.
Als differenzial diagnostisch, also Lungenembolie und Atypische Pnumoni in Betrags.
Zur Abklärung, würde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der Körperlichten untersuchen?
Ich auskultiere den Patienten.
Was erwarten Sie?
Ich erwarte freifelnde Geräusche.
Bei Aus- oder Einatmen?
Ausatmen.
Besonders ausatmen.
Ich auskultiere auch den Herz.
Ich palpiere die Lymphquoten.
Wie heißt das?
Ich habe schon eine EKG geschrieben.
Wie war die Sauerstoff-Lettigung?
Es war 490.
Deswegen habe ich keine Sauerstoff gegeben.
Es reicht schon aus.
Im Blut-Untersuchung überprüfe ich Blutbild-Entzündungsparameter.
Lungenembolie auszuschließen.
Herzparameter.
CK, MB, Troponin-T, Troponin-U.
Um Herzinfarkt zu auszuschließen.
Ich überprüfe auch Nieren-Särkte.
Was ist noch wichtig?
Bei der Blut-Untersuchung.
Sie haben über den Finger-Kripp die Blut-Gas-Analysie gemacht.
Ich erweite die Infiltration.
Ich erweite die Brunschien.
Was für ein Verfahren könnte man noch zur Anwendung bringen?
Ich habe auch das gedacht.
Ich habe die Anwendung von der Blut-Untersuchung gemacht.
Ich habe die Sprache für Asthma gemacht.
Ich habe die Sprache für Spirometer gemacht.
Sehr gut.
Dann halten Sie mich auf alle Fälle über den Patienten.
Wenn Sie das bestätigt mit dem Asthma, haben Sie eine Idee, was die Therapieansatz ist?
Ich fange, ich verschreibe erst mal Cortison-Tablete kurzfristig.
Dann habe ich das vergessen.
Was ist mit dem Pater-Sympathomönen-Methika?
Das ist sehr gut.
Die Prüfer haben hier noch gefragt.
Wichtigste Differenzialdiadenose.
Sie haben die selber schon gesagt.
Lungenembolie, weil das die gefährlichen sind.
Wie nennt man den Akuten Asthma-Anfall?
Ich glaube, das ist nicht so.
Extra-Salvation.
Das ist so etwas, was die Prüferfragen haben.
Wir sind jetzt durch.
Sie informieren mich über den Patienten.
Ich bin sehr zufrieden heute.
Sie haben das schön gemacht.
Sprachlich waren Sie sehr aufmerksam.
Sie haben zwar ein bisschen immer noch geallserut, aber nicht mehr ganz so doll.
Sie haben das schwer kontrolliert.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, Sie haben wieder gefragt.
Und Winnigkeiten.
Wie kommen Sie auf fünf Packiers?
Er hat zehn Jahre ein Päckchen geraucht.
Ja, das ist zehn Packiers.
Ich habe noch etwas gehabt.
Die Mutter hatte Nierensteine.
Sie haben aber gesagt, sie haben Kohlentiersen.
Das sind doch gar Nierensteine.
Das ist Nepholitiasen.
Das ist mir aufgefallen.
Aber sonst, was die Klasse fand, dass sie gleich auf den Renault gekommen sind.
Ja, muss man auch erst mal wissen.
Sehr gut, der hat ja nur beschrieben, aber nicht benannt.
Das fand ich gut.
Und sonst haben sie doch etwas nicht gesagt.
Ja, die Allergien haben Sie bei der Vorstellung nicht erwähnt?
Ja, stimmt.
Muss ich am Anfang erklären oder am Ende normalerweise in Berlin?
Sie fragen immer am Anfang.
Das ist auch ein bisschen ungewöhnlich.
Viele Kollegen machen das später.
Zusammenhang mit den Lebensgewohnheiten.
Fragen, die manchmal noch allergien.
Das ist ein bisschen ungewöhnlich.
Wenn es um Medikamente geht.
Wenn man sagt, brauchen Sie jetzt ein Schmerzmittel,
sind bei Ihnen allergienbekannte.
In dem Zusammenhang wird das gefragt.
Eigentlich hätte man es gut, finde ich,
reinnehmen können im Rahmen der vegetativen Anamnese.
Und das ist natürlich ein klasse.
Das ist natürlich.
Bei den Patienten ist ein Hyperreagie.
Hyperreagie mit Brunchalsystem bekannt.
Er hat eine Allergie gegen Kresse.
Er hat eine Nussallergie.
Die Letztere äußert sich mit Gesichttrötung.
Und dann kann man bei dem Zusammenhang auch noch den Renault ergehen.
Empfindlichkeit zu geben, dass er einen Renus-Syndrom hat.
Also da könnte man es, finde ich, ganz gut über den Vorerkrankungen, die Allergien mit unterbringen,
wenn man sich irgendwo eine vernünftige Stelle dafür suchen will.
Die Kommissionen wollen in Berlin, dass wir am Anfang das Teilen sollen.
Ja, na gut, okay.
Ja, ich habe noch eines Sachen mir aufgeschrieben.
Und zwar haben sie gesagt, dass er schon länger mit mehreren Kissen schläft.
Er hat aber auch so gesagt, dass er das nur in der letzten Nacht gebraucht hat.
Ein Extra-Kissen, also ein Bett höher gestellt hat.
Normalerweise konnte er flach schlafen und hat zwar irgendwie ein bisschen gerustet, regelmäßig,
aber hat trotzdem flach geschlafen, aber das war nur eine Nacht.
Und sie haben gesagt, er hat schon längere Zeit schläft, er mit mehreren Kissen.
Ich habe in den letzten Tagen...
Ja, genau, aber das war nur eigentlich nur eine Nacht.
Normalerweise habe ich so verstanden, aber ich habe so erklärt.
Ja, also mit Windigkeit.
Gut, alles andere würde ich sagen.
Okay, ja.
Und was sie sehr schön gemacht haben, heute, sie haben den Patienten sehr oft mit Namen angesprochen.
Das finde ich immer schön.
Und auch wenn sie so ein bisschen Plikontakt mit der Kamera suchen,
das ist natürlich dann, wenn sie jemanden direkt gegenüber haben, das ist noch viel einfacher.
Ja, dass sie den Patrienten angucken, also ihren Simulationspatienten angucken.
Gut.
Darf ich eine Frage?
Aber immer.
Wie kann man sagen auf Deutsch, Wiesnck oder Sibilan Runkus Wiesnck, wie kann man sagen?
Ich habe nicht verstanden, was man sagen soll.
sagen Sie nochmal was?
Wiesnck.
Oder Sibilan Runkus.
Eine kleine Geräusche heißt Gimen.
Ach, jetzt weiß ich was Sie meinen, die Ausatm-Geräusche.
Ja, genau, Rasseln.
Rasseln, Gimen.
Gimen sagen wir.
Ach, Wiesnck heißt das auf Englisch.
Kann dich nicht auf Englisch.
Und danke schön.
Also wir sagen Gimen, das ist so dieser typische Begriff, Ausatm-Geräusch, genau.
Und dann, was man auch immer sagt, bei der Ausküvitation,
da ist ja immer noch Luft in der Lunge drin.
Die Asthmatiker kriegen ja ihre Luft nicht raus.
Und dann haben die eben einen verstärkten Klopfschall,
weil das wie so eine Trommel ist, wie so eine Lunge aufgebläht.
Und das kann man halt beim Klopfen hören.
Genau, Gimen ist das richtige Wort.
Ja, sorry, ich habe das nicht verstanden.
Gimen heißt im Frontiale Art im Geräusch.
Wunderbar, dass alle zusammenhauen.
Gut.
Ja.
Darf ich noch eine Frage stellen?
Immer.
Aus diesem Thema.
Also in Berlin gibt es einen Fall.
Ein Patient hat vor zwei Tagen Brustschmerzen beim Joggen.
Im Joggen.
Aber im Moment, also in der Vorstellung, hat er keine Beschwerden.
Also er kam zu uns, weil seine Frau so gehen hat.
Ja, okay.
Also wie kann man das während der Arzt-Ansprech erklären?
Also der Patient stellte sich heute wegen Brustschmerzen?
Nein, ja.
Eigentlich muss man sagen, der Patient stellte sich vor,
weil er vor zwei Tagen beim Joggen,
also genauso wie sie es beschrieben haben,
plötzlich heftige Brustschmerzen bemerkt hat.
Und aktuell ist er aber beschwertesrei.
Ja, zur Sicherheit wollte er sich,
oder auf Drängen seiner EFV und zur eigenen Sicherheit,
stellt er sich bei uns vor.
So könnte man das formulieren.
Und ich glaube, dann würde man auch nicht akut sagen,
wir unterbrechen jetzt und machen erst die Untersuchung.
Solange der jetzt akut nix hat,
wäre das ja ein bisschen allwann.
Und ja.
Okay.
Ja.
Ich hoffe, ich konnte Ihnen helfen.
Helfen Sie mir nochmal alles prüfen?